there's a number of effects right I mean
you know this this strike who's a you
know digital creation but we brought all
the experience that we had from you know
working with an actor in the key role on
set like we did with Andy on on rings
with Gollum we went into production with
Shrike with the design that isn't as
design we got it to a point that you
know with a lot of pressure to get
shooting and you know we knew you was
gonna be you know this height he was
gonna be sort of robotic was sort of
part man and we kind of got to this
point where it was yeah okay look that's
good enough for us to shoot words we're
gonna have Steven on set in the suit and
that's fine but let's we've got to keep
going and it wasn't until we finished
shooting and we started seeing Stevens
performance somewhere like well that's
never gonna translate to that design we
should have been a bit more wiser but
you know as part of the process it would
be something that we could then address
and we did and we we then went through
the process of design and Shrike around
Stevens you know face and his
performance you know but he was tricky
because he he wasn't like an animal that
we could take reference from and he
wasn't just a robot that we could make
ignite mechanize he had to be a blend of
the two and he had to be an interesting
design that we you know that we took
that was different to terminator or
Robocop or things that we've seen before
we had to give him his own aesthetic and
his own character and make him very
human yet threatening and you know
robotic and relentless at the same time
in history I histor scar as a digital
makeup and we had a prosthetic which was
sort of very fine but it was as far as
we could push makeup but we wanted her
to be disfigured we wanted to have this
gouge through her face and so we
actually had to do that digitally to
create the actual indication that you
couldn't naturally do there is a way you
used to be able to do it with makeup
which was you'd paint collodion on the
skin and that would actually shrink the
skin and it would like you know that
actually would disfigure you and it's
really bad for your skin and there's
actors that used to use it that have
skin issues now so it's illegal and you
shouldn't use it but and we weren't
gonna do that to Hera so you know so
we've we know we did that digitally the
cities probably are one of the most
difficult aspects because the fact that
everything's moving it really throws it
out when you start moving the
and so we sort of actually approached
some of it in a bit of an old-fashioned
way of just hand modeling everything cuz
it all had to be animatable to move
which usually you don't have to do with
the environments you can build them set
them in place and just let the
simulations run but we actually have to
move out through space so it created a
whole lot of separate problems because
they're not used to having the layouts
that are usually fixed to be in motion
when I investigate it and they read the
books I thought well you're never gonna
be able to pull that off
you know I'd the scale of it the scale
of the cities you know you know rumbling
over the earth yeah I thought that Scott
that you're never gonna be able to
create that scale on screen so that's
what stuck out to me was that it was
going to be impossible to achieve and
yeah and here we are
[Music]